hey 42 here do you often find yourself
getting into arguments for people over
stupid stuff like why the earth cannot
possibly be flat or whether the moon is
genuinely made of cheese and in your own
mind you are almost 100 percent certain
that the earth is obliquely spherical
and the moon is unfortunately not made
of delicious melty cheddar but boring
old rocks yet incredibly you end up
losing these arguments against or to the
moronic people you know you should have
won the argument and you provided them
with countless irrefutable evidence yes
no matter what you say you somehow fail
to change their mind or remotely shake
their ostentatious self-confidence in
their air earnest views why is it so
difficult to argue with stupid people
why do they fail to listen to empirical
evidence and instead favor the wisdom
that that smelly old weird bloke told
them at the pub and why do they often
think themselves far more intelligent
than their words and actions would lead
you to believe let's find out
neuroscientists think there are very
real and fascinating reasons and
explanations for this frustrating
phenomenon but before we talked about
those we must first establish whether
our suspicions are true do people think
they're smarter than they are over the
past 20 years to social psychologists
have been attempting to answer this
question David Dunning and Justin Kruger
David Dunning was inspired to begin this
research after reading a feature in the
1996 World Almanac about a Pittsburgh
bank robber McArthur wheeler who held up
a bank at gunpoint in broad daylight
without a mask but strangely his face
was covered in lemon juice when the
police arrested him later at his home he
said but I wore the juice he explained
how since lemon juices sometimes used us
invisible ink he fought that by covering
his face in lemon juice he would somehow
become invisible to other people and the
security cameras he apparently
a picture of himself whilst wearing the
lemon juice before the robbery to
confirm this theory and remarkably
obvious according to wheelers own
account his face was not visible in the
photo police were never quite able to
explain this but then this is a man who
tried to make himself invisible with
lemon juice so I wouldn't put too much
thought into it inspired by this blatant
idiocy donning teamed up with Krueger
and conducted a series of experiments in
which they got participants to rate
themselves on their grammar logical
reasoning and sense of humor they then
compared the participants self
appraisals with the results of a series
of tests that they asked them to
complete the studies all concluded that
people consistently rate themselves as
being far more competent at everything
than they actually are most people in
the studies performed far worse on the
tests that they believed they had done a
poll in 1980 conducted by a Swedish
psychologist illustrated this nicely
when it showed that 93% of American
drivers considered their driving ability
to be above average just think about
that for a second the maths don't quite
add up the research shows that an
overestimation of our talents is
something we mostly all do albeit some
of us significantly more so than others
and not the more inferior a person's
talents and/or intelligence are then the
greater the degree with which they
overestimate these one of the biggest
factors driving this is two brains
natural egocentric bias first identified
by psychologists in 1979 it turns out
that the brain absolutely loves itself
and does everything it can do to make
itself look good
repeated studies have demonstrated that
the egocentric bias is present in all
types and ages for example we tend to
associate ourselves very closely with
positive events and we take credit for
things that other people have achieved
such as my team played well where as
when our favorite sports team loses we
try to
distance ourselves they performed poorly
similarly we have no problem when we are
over paid for work but we think it's a
bit unfair when overs are we think that
anyone who drives faster than us is a
lunatic yet anyone who drives slower is
an idiot you get the idea your brain
thinks it is the best thing since
single-celled organisms but how does
this relate to winning arguments
basically the brain will do absolutely
anything it needs to in order to save
face your brain must look good no matter
what even if this involves ignoring
facts making up facts or browbeating
you're intellectually superior opponent
into submission now your brain isn't
being a dick for the sake of it
evolutionarily the egocentric bias makes
a lot of sense for self-preservation the
hunter that steals the prey from the
other hunters is a lot more likely to
survive after all our egocentric bias is
so strong that even when we a revocable
II lose an argument we convince
ourselves in our own minds that we
somehow won as the legendary author Dale
Carnegie of the seminal how to win
friends and influence people wrote you
can't win an argument nine times out of
ten an argument ends with each of the
contestants more firmly convinced than
ever that he is absolutely right there
is however another reason why learned
people often walk away from arguments
with those who possess the intellectual
aptitude of a veritable sea sponge
feeling wholly disappointed there is a
general fear amongst a human race of
intelligence even amongst the
intelligentsia themselves this is a very
real phenomenon that numerous
neuroscientists have observed true we
admire those of heightened intelligence
yet we simultaneously fear them in
modern society we have no need to fear
those of superior physical might over
oneself unless you just made a pass at
their wife but say you meet a huge burly
bloke at a dinner party with guns larger
than your entire torso
most of us could converse with him
rather happily without feeling
intimidated yet if we meet a weedy old
professor of astrophysics at a dinner
party who knows general relativity
better than you know where you left your
car keys then suddenly and for reasons
which are unclear to yourself you feel
intimidated by him perhaps you don't if
so congratulations you're probably
rather intelligent or a psychopath
the reasons for this disparity is
strangely related to the egocentric
brain we know how the body builder
gained his mass by relentlessly pounding
the gym and protein we know that if we
could be half as a store inclined as he
then we too could match his level of
esteemed physical prowess and look like
a Soviet tank and most importantly we
can usually predict his intentions and
actions we don't need to be as strong as
him to know what he will probably do if
we piss him off he hits us in the face
yet the scientists unless we are
intellectually superior than he and even
if we are then we will be unable to
predict what he might say or do he could
say something that will reveal our lack
of intelligence and make us look stupid
thus we fear him to compound this fear
unlike the bodybuilder most of us will
feel that even if we read a hundred
books we could never reach the
scientists level of intelligence and
rather pessimistically research supports
the idea that many people are most
likely unable to do so as I have
previously covered in another video we
all have the ability to improve our
crystallized intelligence our bank of
facts and knowledge but once we hit our
mid-20s the brain becomes less
stick it is not totally but mostly set
in its ways the framework of your brain
has been built like a car that has
already been built parts can be swapped
out and polished chopped but ultimately
there's a hard limit to what one can do
with its performance and thus after our
mid-20s we lose the ability to improve
our fluid intelligence that is the
ability to pick up new skills quickly
think on the spot outwit your opponents
and problem-solve so if the scientist
has not only greater crystallized
intelligence but also greater fluid
intelligence than us then we
subconsciously know that this is a level
of mental acuity that we are most likely
unable to ever reach biologically we are
hardwired to be scared of this prospect
and we will feel a natural propensity to
repel that which we cannot better
so you made defensively save something
rather stupid to the scientist even if
it is a joke such as Oh a scientist you
think you're so clever don't you even if
he gave us no obvious reason to feel so
intimidated this has a reciprocal effect
clever people are generally well aware
of others fear and distrust of their
intelligence and so feel less
self-confident when in an argument or
debate would appear even if they know
they could easily win also most people
become intelligent because they have a
proclivity to question their
surroundings and their self intelligent
people are generally more aware of the
fact that they don't know everything
especially in the scientific field it is
normal and expected for one to criticize
their own theories and for their
colleagues and peers to cross-examine
them thus smart people will always
question whether they are as intelligent
as they think they are whether they put
their own point across adequately and if
perhaps their opponent doors in fact
have a point in their ardent cheesy
moon and Flat Earth beliefs as bonkers
as they may sound so they will come away
from the debate with their heads
swirling with questions and self-doubt
conversely stupid people are far less
likely to question things including
themselves they tend to be less
introspective that's probably why
they're still so stupid so they seem and
are far more confidence in their moronic
unfounded theories they don't need to
question them or see how they actually
stack up when confronted with empirical
evidence because they have never done
this before
and they possess not a shred of self
doubt anyway
to add to all this as the dunning-kruger
effect proved stupid people rarely think
of themselves as stupid they have
absolutely no idea that they have less
intelligence than a Swiss cheese as
Dunning and Kruger x' research
demonstrators there is a direct
correlation between a lack of
intelligence and one's high confidence
in their own intelligence and vice-versa
to put it simply inept people think they
are proficient and proficient people
think themselves less so keep in mind
that the dunning-kruger effect is not an
absolute but a general trend not all
stupid people overestimate their
intelligence and some intelligent people
are very aware of how smart they are and
will happily tell anyone who will listen
I'll leave you with a brilliant quote by
the late great comedian George Carlin
that anyone who has ever despaired with
human stupidity will certainly
sympathize with think of how stupid the
average person is and realize half of
them are stupider than that I've
recently launched my first book which
I'm crowdfunding stick a flag in it at
files and years of bizarre history from
britain and beyond the crowdfunding
campaign has reached 100 percent so it's
definitely going to be published thanks
to everyone who has pledged but there
are still stretch goals to reach so if
you want a first edition signed copy
then head on over to unbound publishing
links in the description and pledged
today thank you